many dads work multiple jobs
some help around the house it doesn't
matter what their situation
is their focus is their families
today we highlight one father and their
role to keep their family connected
watch the story of danny lopez my name
is
danny lopez what it means to be a father
to me is
experience the greatest joy you can have
in life to
experience love in its purest form i'm a
father of two girls
danielle my oldest daughter she's 17
about to go to college
my younger daughter sarah she's 16. i'm
a single dad
i've been single for over 10 years
raising both of my daughters
my youngest daughter sarah she was born
with a very um
very unique disability
she was diagnosed with a micro deletion
syndrome so it's a genetic
[Music]
it's a genetic i don't like to use the
word defect
it's a genetic
condition and that condition leads to
very severe developmental delays it
leads to
very severe autism
problems with her motor skills
it's it's a very strange condition
because
there aren't that many cases like this
in the united states
so our routine consists basically of
lots of diaper changes
uh getting uh sarah ready for for her
aba therapy which happens mondays
through fridays
every day sessions in the morning
sessions in the afternoon
i'm very active in the therapy sessions
um
and you know that goes on through a
lunch time and then you
prepare lunch i'm lucky that they like
to eat everything i make
just remember and that you are an
important person
just like moms are important dads are
important
they need you in their life they need
you to be involved
with their lives they need you to pay
attention to them
they are paying attention to you we need
to be there
sometimes we're tired sometimes we just
finish the 12 hour shift
i understand but we need to find that
extra energy and we need to be there for
them
they need us reporting for a news now
natalia ancelotti